I have a condo and I kind of forgot it
was there imagine being so rich you
forgot you own property in Beverly Hills
I'm really lucky well that's exactly
what happened to Kris Jenner during the
season 2 premiere of Hulu's the
Kardashians tune in because you never
know what's gonna happen the Kardashian
Jenner family matriarch makes the
hilarious confession after Chloe pays a
visit to said condo this is a cute
little place but I must say so myself I
forgot you even had this place when was
the last time you've been here Christmas
this is our gift wrapping station this
is Santa's Workshop yeah
condo for gift
to forget I have property somewhere same
Coco
I feel blessed here's the thing
I have a condo and my mom has one and my
cousin has one and we all live nearby I
kind of forgot it was there
that sounds ridiculous doesn't it this
is what we call champagne problems
people no like literally she has a ton
of champagne on hand should they have
any problems
I've never seen so much champagne why is
this all here in case of an emergency
and if you're trying to tally up how
many bottles Chris has stopped away for
a rainy day don't worry I counted oh boy
32 people 32 one for every day of the
month and an extra bottle just for good
measure and yes yes those are bottles of
Dom perion which runs for a cool 220
dollars at a minimum which means that
tiny section of the fridge is holding
over six hundred dollars worth of high
quality premium bubbles it's never a
dull moment I mean when it sat down with
the 66 year old businesswoman in April
before the season one Premiere she did
say we'd be seeing a different side of
the fam I love that the episodes are
more a little bit documentary style and
I think that you have a real insight
into what the girls are doing not only
you know what you see in the press or
whatever but what's really happening
behind the scenes it's just so
interesting to see it from the inside
out and really get a glimpse of what
happens this is definitely a behind the
scenes look and to send you off here's a
behind the scenes look at taking out the
trash Kris Jenner style you take out the
trash good for you just dump it over the
side it pounces down on the sidewalk and
then you go around and pick it up Mom
you can't do that well as long as you
don't hit anybody you're fine oh my God
I'll take it out the front and I'll take
it down when we get back
I'm sure you will
maybe there's a shoot or something just
don't lock yourself out Chris may have
forgotten her real estate gem but for me
this clip will live rent free in my mind
forever I have a condo and I kind of
forgot it was there
that sounds ridiculous doesn't it
[Music]